[Applause]
Joachim Gilley Boo is one of them
Joachim experimented with heroin for
several years but now he's hooked though
he wishes it were different heroin has
become his whole life
now I really want a normal square life
we would go to work in the morning come
home and
evening instead his day is organized
around one simple goal find a heroin fix
my life side down its ruin my life
every morning Joe Hakeem and his
girlfriend Trina commute to Oslo's city
centre there they spend the day selling
magazines hoping to scrape together
enough money to score
midway through the afternoon they can
afford a couple of hits which they get
from their usual dealer
[Music]
this is what the surge of Afghan heroin
is doing to joe Hakeem and Trina
how will it affect addiction across the
rest of the planet
these are the faces of heroin addiction
for decades the popular perception of
heroin has been that it's a dirty
back-alley needle junkie drug that's
because for so many users no matter
where they come from this is where they
end up there's very few people that I
that I've known that could ever do
heroin recreationally you just can't you
get a habit and before you know you've
lost everything no we all start out the
weekend warrior thing we think we can do
it you know we do for a while but
somewhere down the line things fall
apart this is a shooting gallery in the
American Midwest though it could be
anywhere in the world and you hear the
same stories here that you would in Oslo
my marriage would fall apart I'd lose
the house and knowing that all these
things I was doing I still chose heroin
I still chose to do in the heroin these
are long term addicts who've managed to
survive each dose and in turn need each
dose to survive I've been shooting for
probably about 34 years heroin junkies
follow the same endless sequence hustle
score use you're gonna lose everything
[Music]
I used to be a hooker on the streets for
a year two years something like that you
know just to support my habit a heroin
habit can be deceptive and usually
starts slowly if you snorting blows if
you snorting it if you keep snorting it
for a certain amount of years it's gonna
nine times out of ten it's gonna lead to
new
[Applause]